Neil welcome to the podcast glad to have
you on hey I'm Neil I do mechanistic
interpretability research which means I
take neural networks I try to open them
up and stare at the internals and try to
reverse engineer out what algorithms
they've learned
and attempting to take us from the world
where we know that a network is good at
a task to knowing how the network is
good at the task
this is really weird and hard but also
kind of fascinating
all right
lightning rounds yes I want to give you
an impossible task which is to answer
complex questions in a short amount of
time actually answer questions that are
have been unanswered by Humanity for for
a long time in you know three minutes so
are you up for that challenge I strive
to disappoint
so um my first question is because you
have a a background in pure math so how
useful do you do you think advanced
mathematics is how useful is it that we
have had this highly advanced
mathematics that to most people at least
seem to not apply to to the world
so my short answer is not very useful my
solid longer answer is I personally have
benefited a lot from doing a hard pure
maths degree and spending a great deal
of time learning mostly useless very
very hard things that involve thinking
and abstractions and I think this has
totally useful skills even if I've
forgotten most of the knowledge
I
also think that
when I look around me or around the
Cambridge maths department and see some
of the smartest people I know who then
go on to do phds of which maybe five
people in the world care about the stuff
they're researching I can't help but
feel sad that the enormous waste of
human capital
I think that sometimes I'm wrong
um number theory is the classic example
of how could this possibly be useful oh
wait it underlies the modern internet
but
modern maths is just so ridiculously
Niche I would just be so surprised if
the typical area in it was remotely
useful even if there are occasional
lucky gems
do you think that mathematics will be
Advanced by AI in the future and so
perhaps if we get very Advanced AI we
don't
we don't need to do the math ourselves
we can we can rely on an AI to do it for
us and therefore perhaps uh these
Geniuses in the Cambridge Mathematics
Department should be working on AI as
opposed to directly on mathematics
I mean sure seems plausible I do not all
keep up with the field of AI theorem
proving but I gather it's moving pretty
fast and going interesting directions
I mean there's a broad spectrum from AI
is instrumental in solving the next big
problem in maths to
human mathematicians are completely
obsolete
but one of the depressing things about
AI is it gets better a lot faster than
humans get better
and I mean if you know your job's going
to get obsolete it's definitely obvious
you should go and make it obviously
faster
uh if you find doing become as fun and
you're afraid that mathematicians are
going to be outdated in 20 years and
keep you doing more maths now before
you're made obsolete okay what do you
think are the key drivers of
technological progress
ah this does not feel like a thing that
I have unique answers on
human capital new ideas good social
structures like property rights and
incentives for Innovation that get
people to do things having an
environment where people are broadly
safe their rights are respected they are
kind of happy and free people
free exchange of ideas
actual scientific knowledge
funding being allocated to interesting
ambitious people who have ideas that can
change the world
fairly generic somewhat near Liberal
perspective on that this isn't a
question I've thought about that much
what is a scientific discovery that if
it were made would completely disrupt
your worldview so what what scientific
discovery would turn your worldview
upside down
I mean speaking purely personally as an
atheist the existence of the god of the
Bible words pretty dramatically changed
a lot of my worldview
anything anything that that would be
perhaps uh less uh disruptive or closer
to
um I mean in terms of closer to home
there's nothing to be very life
disrupting like the discovery of
meaningful life extension technology
such that I
do not need to expect to die of old age
um incredible anti-obesity drugs uh
which there seems to be really awesome
progress on which is amazing
would predictively change how I think
about my health
that seems to be perhaps an area where
we could make massive progress I imagine
if we had effective anti-obesity drugs
that I mean that would improve so many
lives
um and it's yeah it's I think that's an
under undervalued area of research
perhaps even though we're I know we're
dedicating billions uh of dollars to it
but perhaps even so even in light of
that I think it's undervalued yes I'm
very confused about how resources and
energy are allocated in biomedical
research I'm much more confused by the
comparative lack of investment in things
like anti-aging
but yeah I mean semi-glue tied is the
current hot thing that seems like an
actually effective anti-obc drug which
is incredibly good news
so in terms of life life extension what
what do you think we should be doing
that we aren't doing it just simply
allocating more money or should we is
there some tweak we should make to how
we view aging
So speaking of someone who is not even a
biologist let alone an anti-aging expert
I do not feel remotely qualified to say
any strategic things about the fields I
have the general view that mostly
absorbs from my environment that science
is to still SIDS and centralizes too
much of the funding in established
people with long careers you fit into
established paradigms
and is two incrementalists and
incentivizes people to have fast results
soon and I'm very excited about
experiments like focused research
organizations and finding promising
people and giving them large budgets to
do whatever they think is reasonable
what is a focused research organization
so I'm not very familiar with this
um I believe convergent research is one
of the main places incubating them the
idea is I understand it is
rather than is than an alternate model
for how you could fund science is find
some promising team give them a bunch of
money and say you've got a five-year
timeline to pursue some ambitious task
like
um
reverse engineer the brain of a nematode
worm or something there are examples of
things that actually exist which I don't
know and the organization will wind down
after five years Government funding that
doesn't need to worry about raising
funding and it's got a clear deadline
and it's trying to make as much progress
as it can
to do focused research
and this is like a really interesting
Innovation I know if it'll work but I
love that there are people trying stuff
like this
yeah definitely I think we need to try
different things in science funding in
general
um is there any advice you could give to
a person that feels like he or she is
not living up to to her values uh is
there a way in which we can approach our
values uh better
um such that we feel like we are living
authentically uh in accordance with what
we want to do
sure so
I'm not sure I personally live out my
values as well as I want to
um and if someone does I'm either very
jealous or very skeptical but one thing
which has been pretty important to me
broadly feeling happier about this whole
thing is accepting that I just have a
bunch of different values I care a lot
about doing good on the world and making
the world refer and there's an
instrumental thing there making powerful
ai go well and understanding how to
interpret it
but also I care a lot about social
approval I care about feeling like I
have status I care about
Comforts and having enough money they
don't need to worry about money I care
about
just kind of not being in danger and not
care about my physical safety I value
intellectual joy and fulfillment and
Novelty and just following the shiny
thing and these are all values you can
have many values uh to me the path to
being an authentic person who has who
satisfies their own values does not look
like
figure out your true aesthetic value of
like do the most Goods or build human
knowledge and I think that a mistake
that I have made in the past thinking
that this is my only value and these
other things aren't real things I care
about it's to try to align these values
together
and find ways to set up your life so the
various things that aren't necessarily
the same
aligned as much as possible which in my
case looks like finding a research area
that's important but also incredibly fun
yeah that seems like fantastic advice so
trying to align the different goals that
are within yourself such that you're
achieving goals that you find most
important
yes and importantly treating this as
like an actual challenge this is not an
easy thing this is not something you
just like oh obviously I just go
Um become a researcher in this area that
satisfies everything I want it's a thing
that can take years of work and
iteration and I am nowhere near complete
apps but it's a thing where deciding to
actually try and then be willing to take
creativity
I don't know it's not listening to this
and kind of Vibes my challenge to you is
pause this set a five minute timer
brainstorm
what you could actually do to better
align the different values you have and
see if you have any actual ideas
because this is hot
yeah great advice
um so if we imagine a person a thousand
years ago I would generally think that
this person has uh worse empirical
beliefs than I do and perhaps also worse
values than I do
and I think many people would agree with
that but do you think that there's
anything we could learn from this person
say a a person a thousand years ago from
from England or from from India or
wherever is there anything where they
have more wisdom or perhaps even what
they have better empirical beliefs than
we do
my short answer is just no the world
seems vastly better and more sensible
and more moral and more educated
and basically always I care about I
think that there's General value to
having an outside perspective
any cultures full of is a bubble full of
its own false belief it's hard to knows
from the outside and I think any outside
perspective can be valuable there but
I don't know I expect I could get more
out of talking to someone from China or
some other fairly culturally different
country today than I would out of
talking with someone a thousand years
ago
all right
let's say that Humanity solves AI
alignment we now have a an artificial
general intelligence that is on our side
that sounds great that's great what
should we then do what's uh how how are
we going to live in such a world what
what would we spend our time doing would
we even exist as we currently think of
of humans
um how would we have fun in such a world
I mean this just massively depends on
exactly how things shake out and what
technologies are made what people want
to do I mean the kind of cliche answer
is there's a singularity we all get
uploaded to the cloud and it's a
glorious transhumanist Utopia but lots
of people don't want that I think
tracking what people want is important I
think that probably if you had a human
level AI That's also kind of cheap
enough to run then like in a practical
way you could dramatically increase the
rate of technological progress
good in a bunch of ways concerning a
bunch of other ways can be pretty
destabilizing to society when a bunch of
things kind of progress at different
rates
I
um there's a really hot problem can we
get a human level AI just hold this for
us
uh this is totally leaving aside
questions about
um well actually the first important
thing we should do is you know go and
fix all of the problems in the world
today like have enough of an economic
surplus that no one is in poverty
um cure all diseases figure out climate
change
figure out how to like eradicate all
disease
that kind of thing
that's like my actual highest priority
then there's all the random
transhumanist speculation
do you think there is a sense in which
if we succeed in this task and in
general solve all of the problems that
you just mentioned that life would
become boring in some in some
horrifically uh reverse way that we
would we would sit there and become
bored
I'm kind of skeptical I feel like if you
believe this or life just sounds kind of
dull
like
I don't know I work on things because
they're fun and interesting lots of
people in my life I enjoy getting to
know I enjoy learning new things
this does not require some deep meaning
of there being problems in the world
and I kind of think that if you can only
be happy there's problems in the world
it seems kind of shitty
it definitely would be a bad
psychological disposition but I'm
thinking for example you what I what I
hear from you is that you're fascinated
by by a different difficult mathematical
problems imagine just that all of these
problems have been solved by a very
Advanced AI isn't there a sense in which
you draw meaning from challenges
um and from unsolved problems
so I do think there is
some meaningful sense in which a world
where there is some Authority who is
just more competent than you who you
trust and look up to and he can kind of
do everything you might want to do is a
qualitatively different world than the
world today
I would guess people often kind of
exaggerate how much this matters we're
just on a day-to-day basis this is not
actually that relevant like I do
research for me has anyone done this
before is an important question like if
I'm reading a book hmm doesn't matter I
like reading the book I like learning
things if I'm meeting new people and
forming friendships it's just a source
of joy in my life
and I do think that it would be sad in
some aesthetic sense if
Humanity just cease to be an important
part of Science and progress
but in terms of just
how I think most ordinary people's lives
would go I don't know it was like
hundreds of millions and billions of
people in extreme poverty and I think
they're going to be complaining
definitely not I agree
um what is an what is an important
concept that is often misunderstood
so one coming to mind is
consequentialism where I feel like lots
of people have takes on consequentialism
at the moral theory of do things that
they have good consequences that are
like oh if everyone was consequential it
would all go around killing people for
their organs
um or the world would be a terrible easy
you can trust anyone and it's just like
that sure sounds like a negative
consequence that it comes to the
consequentialist should care about
and that actually I think what people
are arguing against is the kind of naive
utilitarianism or naive consequentialism
of not actually thinking about the
second order effects of your actions
and I feel like with thought experiments
people often like wildly miss this where
you just you're not actually in practice
get a scenario where you can kill one
person for their organs say five other
people and there's zero consequences no
one will ever find out and this has no
effect on the social fabric
what do you think is the most uh
impressive scientific discovery relative
to the time in which it was discovered
pox vaccination
both because a eradicating smallpox is
just objectively one of the most
impressive things Humanity has ever done
and also I believe the first time it was
discovered was in the late 1700s or
early 1800s
and it is just wild that at a time with
such poor knowledge of medicine people
figured out oh this terrible deadly
disease can be prevented if you get
yourself this
weaker disease and to some degree did
actual experiments
is it the case that books are outdated
what does that dated even mean I mean
physical books are in some ways
superseded by ebooks uh they're not sure
that's the spirit of the question and
many people disagree
let me let me rephrase that uh the
spirit of the question is I want to
learn a complex area of
um human knowledge is the case that I
shouldn't use a book or a textbook and
that I should perhaps work through
exercises on a website or read papers or
so do you find do you think books are
are outdated in that sense
I'd be pretty surprised I feel that
oh I mean this just kind of feels like
the wrong question I think how the best
way to learn something generally looks
like
follow the guidance of an expert on how
best to learn it find just clean
distilled versions of the concepts
generally if someone composite writes a
good textbook that's like a great thing
to read and work through
sometimes the people who could write
good textbook could write articles
instead or like write blog posted lists
of exercises and sometimes the advice is
ah you shouldn't read a book you should
like your right code or like go out in
the world and try this thing
but I don't see how this is like
different about today except in that I
don't know the internet means that
they're getting access to articles
relative to books is comparatively
easier there's also things like I don't
know I've been learning web development
recently I just asked chatgpt everything
and it goes surprisingly well
so that's a sense of what books might be
outdated that was exactly the the spirit
of the question actually I was looking
for whether you think that we could
learn more efficiently from language
models rather than textbooks
I think that current language models are
so wildly unreliable and non-robust that
use them as an assistant when doing
something where you get feedback whether
you've been taught something that's BS
or not seems great use them in a context
where you just don't know how to tell
the difference it seems insane
yeah because it can be if language
models will often give you answers that
that might sound plausible if you know
very little about an area it will give
you confident sounding answers in the
same way that it will get give you
answers in an area and you know
something about but if you it can be
difficult to differentiate between the
the BS answers and the the real answers
yes this is one of the many reasons that
I would like to be able to better
understand these models and what's going
on inside of them
that would be incredibly useful I I have
just been really impressed with how good
chat gpts at explaining web development
to me though
and it's the kind of venue domain where
I'm happy learning from a language model
that's deeply unreliable because I just
run the code and check would you think
that chat gbt is especially good here
since there's probably a lot of text on
the internet about learning web
development
honestly I would guess that a lot of it
is that I believe Chachi PT was heavily
trained on codes as well as text
and it seems generally good for coding
tasks
because I can do things like write
Snippets that sometimes just work
should settling Mars be a priority for
Humanity
um
uh priority is unclear
um do I think that settling Mars is the
best way to reject existential risk no
not at all I think that
even in the reference class of living on
Mars making a super bunker on earth that
is
like insulated from anything including
pandemics
and where people only enter or exits
like once a year or something seems a
lot more cost effective than going to
Mars
if I think go to Mars would be awesome
Yes uh do I think it's plausible that
going to Mars is like a better use of
resources than many other things that
the economy optimizes also yes
I Nerf the world spends billions of
dollars on ice cream
seems multiple that redirecting some of
that to going to Mars is a good trait
well okay this kind of thing is messy
because numbers and counter factuals are
weird but
yeah
um arguably going to the Moon is about
significant technological developments
though it's very hard to tell fact from
that's a really nice story which isn't
actually true and these contexts
how do you focus on your work is there
anything you do to to not get distracted
and to do deep work
I am just pretty bad at this is the
first thing I should say which also
means I've had lots of times trying and
failing to solve this things to do that
are pretty helpful
um disable Wi-Fi on my laptop if I'm
doing some offline writing
uh or if I'm being particularly
distractible ton of Wi-Fi laptop and uh
commits to pay my girlfriend 20 pounds
if I turn it back on before I finish the
task block out a day with no calls or
other things during which is intended
for just
Focus hard on my top priorities
and
prioritize hard at the start of the day
um her working with people where we
check in every 25 to 50 minutes with
each other uh on how we're doing certain
tensions potentially watch each other
screens
there's this website called
focusmates.com which I really like which
just matches you with some random
stranger for a co-working video call
also doing things you like rather than
things you don't like really effective
but do you find it still a problem even
though you work on something that you do
like working on
oh yeah yes my executive function could
be way better
do you see any problems with
relationships between humans and AIS I'm
thinking about romantic relationships
between a an AI chatbot and a human
so
um I generally try to be open-minded and
not judge things I
do think that on a purely aesthetic
level I find that if someone falling in
love with a kind of fiction or a kind of
misunderstanding or superficial veneer
on some computer program kind of
unsettling in the same way that I don't
know if someone falls in love with
someone they meet on the internet and
they're actually being catfished by a
scammer I think this is a tragedy even
if the person's life is genuinely really
enriched by the interaction with the
scammer
I also think lots of people are really
lonely loneliness is like really really
bad and but if AI can help people be
less lonely this seems pretty good
it's a complicated question
I also think that figurines kind of
question out it's not the kind of thing
that Society is very good at and I sure
wish there was someone whose job it was
to solve these issues he was actually
accomplished about it
are there aliens in the universe
um probably
just many planets
seems really weird to think that Earth
is the only place
the fact that we haven't seen any is
definitely evidence against but it's not
strong evidence against
do you think we will ever as a species
bump into these aliens
I mean I expect us to get AGI first
and that's more than alien enough for me
I
do you think that the most likely
outcomes for Humanity are either go
extinct or colonize the Stars
and I think that once you start
expanding throughout space if there are
aliens you will eventually meet the
aliens
what are some of your favorite books
that you think the audience should read
a book very close to my heart is
um Harry Potter and the methods of
rationality by eliezie utkowski which is
uh this Harry Potter fan fiction that he
wrote to try to model clear thinking and
rational behavior and I read this when I
was 14 and thought it was amazing I now
reread it and I like there are so many
flaws in the character that I did not
realize before was when I was 14. but
ulcer this is still like a great book
but I got a lot out of reading uh so I
really like that one
I think the allowed Problem by Brian
Christian is pretty great and is
probably my favorite description of
alignment flavored concerns in real
current day AI models I'm a bit confused
about there's also just like really well
I really like it
um the precipice by Toby orbs I think is
a pretty solid just why existential risk
is a thing you might be concerned about
that is pleasantly well explained
and broadly says reasonable things
what is an overlooked positive aspect of
humanity
we live in a world where it's just not
that hard to do quite a lot of damage in
a variety of ways I don't know make
bombs from household materials and very
very few people do this
and there are just lots and lots of ways
that affect against Society in a way
that no one really knows us and this
mostly does not happen at least in
I know West the West I was just kind of
great
yeah so the world is is fragile but the
fact that it hasn't been destroyed yet
or the fact that we we don't see more
um bad things happening is a testament
to most humans being good perhaps
kind of I think
trying the world is much more in the
edges of nation-state actors Etc with
nuclear weapons or gain of function
research labs and very terrifying things
like that and I think that those seem
concerning you know an entirely
different way but just
there are not that many people who try
to kill other people there's just a
great thing about the world
do you think people should spend more
resources and time uh prepping so
prepping for disasters by storing food
or storing tools this used to be
something something of a left at
subculture but perhaps covid-19 has has
changed that in a way in which it's it's
now more obvious to more people that
that it would be useful to have
some general basic prepping by done by
by more people
I kind of think everything is ultimately
a cost benefit trade-off I think that
people do systematically overestimate
How likely things are to be basically
normal
and underestimate How likely there is to
be big weird disasters like covet that
dramatically change things
I also think that it's very easy to fall
in the opposite trap of investing a
large amount of your resources and time
and energy into preparing for things and
I think that with everything you should
80 20.
just understanding the kind of common
natural disasters that happen where you
live and being pretty robust like
extreme versions of those
having enough Foods that's and power
such that if utilities get cut off
you're like not screwed
um but I kind of feel like prepping is
just an unusually Salient example of the
general thing of bad things happen like
I don't know as a young person
probably
one of the biggest risks to me beyond
death is that I
end up in some situation which
dramatically decreases my future earning
potential or like you know some kind of
brain damage or significant disability
and probably should have some insurance
against that I don't maybe I should fix
this
but to me it's definitely not obvious
that not prepping is a mistake if you
also don't have things like that
got it what advice would you give to
teenagers listening to this
explore try out a bunch of things
take seriously the idea that there can
be things you actually care about if you
can just find them
um don't fall into the traps I fell into
where you think that school or
university is
the only thing that matters and that
getting good grades and pleasing the
authority figures in your life is the
main metric by which success is measured
but also don't think that it doesn't
matter at all it's kind of stuff as
instrumentally useful and sometimes
correlate thinks that actually matter
try to figure out what you actually care
about and how you can actually take
action towards this
and don't just follow the default paths
the world lays out in front of you
but actually check what defaults you're
on and check whether you're happy
remaining on them I can say that this is
advice that would have been useful to me
as a teenager so yes the people are
interested I have many posts of Life
advice on my blog at neilnanta.io some
of which might even be useful yeah I
recommend listeners go read some of
those
um if we look at if we look at the
generative AI models like chat TPT or
Dolly how do you see these models
evolving over the next five years so
what do you think they'll be able to do
and how do you think they'll impact
Society
sure so brief answer bigger better more
General more impressive
I expect lots of the current jankiness
around being somewhat unreliable uh
needing to do a bunch of delicate prompt
engineering to get it to do exactly what
you want are going to go away as they
kind of already have chat GPT is a
notable Improvement on gpd3 in terms of
kind of a usability and user interface
even if it's not actually that much
better in terms of what I can actually
do
I think that
dolly for videos seems like a thing
that's possibly going to be a thing in
the next five years
I
expect that a much larger fraction of
software engineering jobs is going to be
done with co-pilot style models do you
have an interesting idea of how much can
be achieved in the world uh interacting
with it only through an an internet
connection or browser
seems like quite a lot
I think there's a bunch of stuff that
the world that Society tries to make
require you to have a physical presence
an identity
New York customer regulations needing to
show a Passport to have the right to
work somewhere
Etc which make it much harder to do like
you can't do them via a browser but it
requires
significantly more sophistication to
interface with society's systems but
beyond stuff like that and no I didn't
go out of my house much during 2020 my
life was pretty functional in terms of
my ability to interact with the world
and do things
and I I ask this of course because if
you have a language model there is some
way to have it generate a list of tasks
or a plan in a list and then perhaps
translate that list into actions in a
browser and if a lot can be achieved in
a browser then perhaps the language
models are more capable of affecting the
world than we might believe
yes I
do not think that the bottleneck on
language models being scary right now is
the limitations of what you can do in a
browser I think you do a lot in a
browser
and the kinds of AI risks I'm concerned
about look a lot more like a competent
manipulative system with internet access
that you're like an army of Killer
Robots but I'm also concerned about the
army of Killer Robots to be clear
let's end it here Neil
um this has been interesting and uh
thank you for coming on the podcast
yeah this was fun thanks a lot for
having me on